Southern Nevada Water Authority is
cracking down on Water use everywhere
including our Valley's golf courses
Sports director Chris Matthews joining
us with more on the impact that water
conservation will have on area courses
Chris yeah it really will beginning in
January golf courses will start making
changes to comply with the strict but
important mandates to cut back on water
use one course in Clark County has
already made the change
desert city that's green and alive is a
mirage especially grass Las Vegas is the
fourth driest metro area in the world
well it's in the top five on Earth and
it's certainly by a lot the driest in
the United States this is the driest
metro area water is precious but so is
golf it's a big business in fact golf's
direct economic impact in Nevada is two
billion dollars with an indirect impact
reaching 1.2 billion but the snwa is
teeing off on Golf Course water use and
demanding courses reduce their water
usage from 3.6 acre feet per irrigated
acre to four feet The member-owned
Anthem Country Club in Henderson is
swinging into action five months ago
they shuttered the course replacing
every Fairway with drought tolerant Turf
but just by switching from cool season
to warm season grass you're going to
save 30 off the top which translates
into 30 million gallon saved annually
just by replacing 35 Acres with a more
heat tolerant Bermuda grass and I'm very
proud of our club for getting ahead of
the the curve on having to do it we were
redoing greens anyway the members were
locked out of their course for over five
months enough time for the 1.7 million
square foot major makeover our goal is
to save water and be the steward in the
community and that's why we moved ahead
to do this right away with the members
only ribbon cutting ceremony which
apparently cutting water usage is easier
than cutting a ribbon Anthem is now a
leader in water conservation in southern
Nevada
all right and by the way the cost of
changing over all the fairways and
redoing those greens at The Anthem
Country Club is costing members millions
of dollars so compliance doesn't come
cheap but again it's saving 30 million
gallons annually Kirsten